well I'm doing unscripted video on code
Tecna tutorials where anything could
happen because I didn't plan any of this
I just have a topic I'm gonna rant on it
for a while so that's the context that's
the context of this video and I'm in my
high on my high dynamic range phone
according to Joshua fluke he may have
proved this dynamic range I don't know
anyway doesn't matter what I want to
talk about is working with people that
you don't want to work with or rather
choosing not to work with them if you
have the choice time you don't have a
choice if you're being hired and you're
working with a company you might not
have much of a choice you can go
complain to your boss but then you're
known as the complainer so how's that
work out I don't you gotta find a
bouncer that's difficult but I have it a
few specific examples in mind of things
that have happened recently in my life
say within the last year or two so I
play a little Magic the Gathering with
some friends and I kind of picked it up
a lot at recently I played a lot when I
was a kid and I recently just started
playing again with some friends at play
commander and I've been having a really
good time and they're their group had
been going on for a long time they had
been playing for for years and years and
I sort of just joined them and well some
things were happening within their group
I don't want to reveal too many personal
details so basically there was a fallout
with some of the old members not
everybody was getting along not
everybody was agreeing and there was
some turbulence among the group and when
I came in I just started hearing stories
stories about people's stories about all
players
stories about things that happen stories
about people who used to come some event
happened someone blew up they never
showed up again and we started to notice
some trends so I want to talk about a
little bit of those and it's interesting
that old friends people have known each
other from you for years will come
together play play a game just to hang
out there's no reward there's no prize
it's not a tournament you're just really
there to have some fun in you know
smacks them for friends around and have
some stories to tell them that sort of
thing it's just you know it's all fun
and games it's not too serious but there
were a few players whose
showing up because basically they would
throw a fit and rage if they didn't win
I'm not kidding 30-plus year old males
throw a fit over of Magic the Gathering
game and not winning or their combo not
going off or their critical card getting
countered by somebody with literally
literally throw fits and in yell and
scream like you know like two or three
year olds so when here in these stories
and when John joined this group I was
just like really that guy know I've
known him since high school what he
still rages that stuff like this what
kind of life is he living all right and
it sounds like I'm bashing the guy and
that's because I am that that's really
done so we have this little group where
we you know organize and get it together
and someone made the I forget how it
started but someone made the comment
like it was that was fun
or actually I think I mean I made a
little recap post of a last night's
games really fun
here's a quick rundown of them I like to
do that so we kind of remember him
because some of them are really
interesting a lot of interesting
politics go on it you know it's all fun
and games we have a laugh and you know a
game like commander it's like you're
trying it's it's a very political thing
you're trying to kind of trying to it
feels like you're trying to rule the
world trying to own the world or
something and you got to conquer every
other every other player and you can't
just do it right out because if you get
too powerful everybody else comes
against you so you got to sort of play
your cards right to appear like you're
not too strong that everybody wants to
come at you and you got to do in a way
where people kind of like you sooner or
not everybody kills you you also want to
appear too dangerous so you could only
get up late
you play your stuff at just the right
time when it's too late and nobody can
do anything about it and it's so fun
it's very it's very nuanced and I really
enjoy it but some people can't handle it
so I posted this recap and and I
basically was like you know point now
who won in his response was something
like oh I made this little wind tracker
to keep track of of winds it was just
like a you know spreadsheet
and replied with a not too concerned
exactly with wooden ratios and stuff
like that just kind of recap in the
stories someone else said something like
yeah it's more about what happens in the
game than who wins and then the other
person replied I mean this is why I no
longer play commander and we were all
just like wait what so little backstory
this was the guy who would would rage
30-something male would literally rage
if people shut him down in the game and
he played decks that were like pure
combo he tried to win on turn three kill
everybody on turn two or three and then
we would get mad when people counter to
stuff and say what would he expect we
want to have a chance of course we're
gonna counter your stuff we're not just
gonna let you win and he would just
braid about so you know you stop showing
up and it's apparently his reason was
that he doesn't even care what happens
in the game according to his post his
words doesn't doesn't matter at all what
happens in the game and all that matters
is that he shows up and he's allowed to
win I don't know if he wants it he's one
of those guys that likes participation
trophies cuz that that's sort of what
it's like if people just let you win
it's like giving you a participation
trophy but no that's not the way it is
you know that's just the games no fun
like that and he didn't he didn't get
that so he just raged quit sad sad so
the point is you're gonna have to work
for people like that people like that
exists and in general he's a very smart
guy and I just apparently has rage and
can't handle loss issues so some people
are like that and you know they're out
there in the world some of those people
if they have it really bad they can't
even get a job because you know the
managers are hiring managers or whatever
just see that and be like no way no way
I'm lying that guy into the company so
hopefully he gets over that and it's
able to actually find a some real work
and work on those issues but that's a
thing that is a thing and there was
there was a couple other guys like that
too apparently and it seemed to be a
trend from just from hearing the stories
since I joined
group of people wouldn't blow up one day
usually about not winning and then
they'd not show up again and it's like
sorry we just don't have free free one -
you got to earn it you know and you got
to earn it by being cool playing your
cards right and not getting everybody
against you so that's just the way it
goes and most of us like to play decks
that are like we just know if we play a
really powerful deck once people become
aware that we're playing that deck it
just turns into it oh you got to shut
him down or he's gonna he's gonna blow
up and kill everyone and one thing and
just run away with the game so that
becomes known and for that reason a lot
of us tone down our decks just so we
have a chance of winning cuz replays is
really powerful decks you win a game or
two and then it just becomes annoying
because it's the same thing of everybody
trying to shut you down and then they
play their game after they shut you down
and it's really it's really not a whole
lot of fun so that's kind of an
interesting commander thing so yeah I'd
like to play theme decks of some sort I
don't want to talk too much about my
decks maybe I'll do a video later all
right
I'm sort of thinking about making a
channel more related to just magic stuff
and talking about this source stuff so
let me know if you guys want to see
something like that I can reference it
later but basically I have this my a
couple famed sort of becoming famed for
just you know being my decks like I have
this demon deck and it's not super
powerful but it's pretty consistent and
I tend to win a lot of games just
because I'm not seen as a giant threat
people don't want to kill me instantly
but I can handle things got a lot of
removal it's got a lot of big creatures
and late-game it's just like it brings
it home pretty often and one of the
reasons is because people will fight
each other over me if I'm just kind of
sitting back and they know if I they
attack me I'm gonna send my removal out
of it
and things like that it's more about
building defense sometimes too so
another example sort of a side thing not
really related to magic so much but this
is this is a family member
I don't know much want to talk about
this but I'll just glaze over it as sort
of another example of how how we're
aging doesn't work out and they end up
having to work with these people so I've
had someone that pretty consistently has
been a rager their whole life and you
know that okay I should clarify I don't
think there's particularly anything
anything that wrong with being mad or
getting mad just sort of I always see it
as a sign that you need to change
something or something needs a changed
sure I've been mad at things before I've
yelled me when maybe I shouldn't have
but it's always hindsight 20/20 and it's
it makes it makes it says a lot about
you if you can go back to that person
and say look I made a big mistake I
should have got some manager just
addressed the issue the right way to
begin with and just learn from me you
know it's everybody makes mistakes it's
not that big of a deal and if you can do
the right thing and own up to it and say
hey look I'll try to do better I
recognize that that wasn't good way and
that means a lot that means a lot of
people I have only had that just a very
few people come to me and say that later
and if I ever catch myself doing
something like that I make it a point to
go back to him and say look I recognize
what I did was wrong I just started
doing that and it just definitely saved
me friendships there's no doubt about
that
there's I'll get back to the other story
in a second but I just thought of
something else
so a guy worked with was being super
annoying one one day he and another
student worker were goofing off and they
just started like I don't know they were
just bored I guess and that just started
kind of insulting people and just kind
of ragging on people and they started
doing it at me and I just like I just
kind of got mad and shut him down
real hard very very very neatly I don't
remember exactly what I said but one of
the guys was like at the end of it I saw
like tears come into his eyes and him be
like geez geez man that that hurts and
not just hurts that hurts like in here
and I'm like no I'd be only too far but
maybe you shouldn't have been do
what you were doing because that was
pretty absurd too so yeah I shut him
down real hard probably too hard
he definitely too hard no doubt about
that but it definitely got the point
across and they become became much
cooler and definitely much more
respectful of me as far as not like
being so dang childish you know it was
like six seven year old stuff so but I
felt bad because he said how much what I
said back to him hurt him and I was like
oh geez I didn't want to I didn't mean
to go there I'm gonna end up ruin in the
friendship so I talked to him about it
later I was like look yeah you're right
I did take it too far I didn't mean all
that stuff I was just really annoyed and
you know I apologized this sincerely as
I could to him and he was like it's all
right
and to this day we still talk we're
still cool I'm still friends so you know
we moved past that moment that's that
sort of a side thing but you know
everybody everybody's guilty at some
point but it's important to recognize
really important so back to the other
example of the family member rages at
stuff he has some set of issues that are
beyond anyone's control I think but you
know just things have never have not
worked out well for this person in a
long time because this person has not
addressed their underlying issues they
just seem to address the it's like
taking pain medicine when really all you
need to do is like cut out the tumor or
something you can you can get rid of the
problem permanently am I just dealing
with it at the source or you can just
rage at the results it's giving and
that's pointless because it's never
gonna solve anything
I think that's all I'm going to say
about about that issue but there's also
the issue of being too nice so a lot of
people we used their meanness or the
cruelness as a way to manipulate people
I see this all the time to see try and
think how much I want to say about this
really but okay I have a young son and
he's always he's always trying to push
people's boundaries is very pushy
all right push a kid and I'm always
trying to like settle down and be like
look you're getting mean you're not
gonna get your way for being me and
usually I can settle him down he can't
really hurt my feelings
he says stuff to try to emotionally
badger people to get what he wants you
know it's a kid thank you just testing
testing limits so I don't take it
personally
but I've seen him really hurt some other
people like it's grandma this Grand Hall
doesn't give him what he wants he gets
mad I'll call her names whatever he'll
just try things and she gets really
upset by that and I'm just like oh no if
you start getting upset and giving your
only teaching them to do it again so
it's it's a tricky thing and it's the
same with the workplace - you let people
push you around
you'd be too nice you give them what
they want because they ask for it or
upset about something they'll they'll
see that as a solution and they're do it
again and they'll and they'll keep with
their ridiculous behavior basically and
it's not too uncommon for grown grown
adults to be incredibly childish
childish just like I talked about what
there's a like commander magic it's uh
it's pretty prevalent panic it hurts a
lot of us well and if you let it hurt
you it hurts you but it's important to
recognize that there are people like
that and they will try to emotionally
getting them just try to get under your
skin to try to get what they want and
try to get you to give in and you know
okay I if you notice someone doing that
it's just important to recognize their
method that that's what I think because
then you can make a more informed
decision maybe it is best to get in
maybe some of their points are valid and
maybe enough of them are valid for you
to be like okay I see because of this
and this that makes sense okay we're
gonna we're gonna go forward and other
times it might be like look it's
something you need to do when you're in
this isn't even my problem you're just
trying to get me to band-aid something
that you need to solve and I'm not gonna
do that because it's a waste of my time
I'm gonna waste your time you need to go
solve the underlying issue
so when you recognize their method of
trying to emotionally badger you or
someone or you see it happening anywhere
or maybe they're doing it to themselves
who knows it it just allows you to kind
of get to the core of the problem a
little easier and that's really what I
wanted to to talk about here it's
something I've started to notice as I've
gotten older and wiser and it's
interesting and it saves you a lot of
heartbreak especially with with women
and relationships to like once you
recognize this stuff it's it's really
hard for a woman to hurt you again in
any way because you're just like yeah
you're real emotional but what do I care
about you know it's like your points
aren't very good though so you know
there's a million other other people out
there I don't have to put up with this
crap so it's things like that that will
allow you to move forward in a better
direction if you can if you can
recognize it I think that's gonna do it
for this talk let me know your comments
down below subscribe hit the bell if you
want to see more content more talks more
tutorials more stuff from this channel I
recently started a patreon haven't put
much up on there yet but if you can do
anything there please do it I don't make
anything from doing these yet I hope to
one day but I would like to get some
support and so I can do better videos or
videos at some point it's it's gonna hit
some sort of breaking point or either I
can do this full-time or I can't so I'm
sort of in-between right now and your
support matters a lot thanks have a good
one peace out guys